[Musique]
joyeux noël et à très bientôt
tu sais ce concours de pâtisserie de
noël dont tu parles plus tôt ouais
comité de sélection de belgravia est
heureux de vous inviter à notre concours
international de pâtisserie dno
incroyable mais vrai
[Musique]
c'est qu'elle souhaite noël est vraiment
une période magique j'aimerais juste
avoir quelqu'un avec qui il pas mes
voeux de noël se réalise toujours
[Musique]
je suis vraiment désolé sonnerie en cas
de problème tiède voulait dit margaret
de la cour du chef de monteynard je suis
stacy de nos voix je pense que nous
étions destinés à nous rencontrer
je suis censé épousé le prince édouard
le jour de la je déteste être sous les
projecteurs tout ce que je voulais au
départ c'était vivre une vie de fille
normale
je veux que nous échangions nos vies nos
échangions dauphin je veux devenir vous
et que vous vous baignez mois sérieux
vous aurez tunique moins pendant deux
jours personne ne s'en apercevrait stacy
de nos beaux sacs à jos à gaz ont fait
un peu trop que ça
je pense qu'il est temps d'y aller si
vous dites au bout venant me voilà comme
moi je suis déterminé à passer le plus
de temps possible avec vous pendant les
prochains jours voilà une nouvelle
formidable petit déjeuner presse ça met
du bonnet quelque chose je crois que je
suis un peu stressé à cause de la
pression du concours qui approche
[Musique]
allez lens est bien est ce que ça va je
veux que vous surveiller de très près la
duchesse elle allait re différentes
désolé je regrette ce n'était pas très
digne et ça ne m'a pas déplu
noël est pour moi synonyme d'amour
je n'ai jamais vu aussi sortir peut-être
que tu ne me connais pas si
je pensais pas que les choses
deviendraient si compliqué alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr de pouvoir continuer
tout va bien ouais ça va très bien
[Musique]
tous les cadres de notre boîte sont
bardés de diplômes
la seule chose qui peut arrêter c'est
toi vous avez déjà fait un point sur
votre vie en vous demandant comment vous
en étiez arrivé là si vous choisi était
différent sauriez-vous plus heureux
arthur a obtenu un master radio khalid a
le meilleur profil pour ce poste lors
monsieur c'est moi
je voudrais vivre dans un monde où les
débrouillards sont aussi valorisé que
les intellos je les emmerde à qui tous
ces super diplômés avec leur jolie
maison leurs gosses qui ont des noms de
fruits et leur ascension du kilimandjaro
car si un coup de fil pour un entretien
d'embauché au maire jean franklyn clark
votre cv m'intéresse business school de
word comme quand on regarde son
incroyable page facebook page facebook
obama j'étais fabriquer une nouvelle
identité
tu voulais être au top niveau alors j'ai
fait de toi une cendrillon en mode cloud
c'est vrai que tout ça vient d'un
mensonge d'état décrocher jack ma belle
qui sait la championne à l'écouté quoi
machine champions perte est une
championne à lyon toutefois ça va être
difficile d'avoir un job à votre âge
c'est ce qu'on verra à albi ça va tu
mets tout ce que tu veux sauf ça on
dirait madame doubtfire voir c'est mon
bureau ils ont filé un appartement et
des cartes de crédit faut pas que tu
prennes sages les gardes tu touche pas
et j'ai embarqué sous peu tu vas leur
avouer la vérité après je peux y arriver
vargas ce sont mes amis de norton
wharton en a fait beaucoup
d'humanitaires on a sauvé des baleines
[Musique]
je ne confonds pas ta vie sur facebook
avec qui tu es vraiment je vous admire
beaucoup dans quelques années je
voudrais tellement vous ressemble
[Musique]
tu as toujours été au top que tu es la
seule a en tout cas nous aimerions nous
implanter en chine est la seule employée
qui parle monde arabe
moi j'ai une idée note veto parle
couramment mandarin
nous serons ravis de vous faire une
visite guidée tandis que la corse aussi
et d'abord des trafics au jeu l'adorent
[Musique]
thorpe à 7h55 s'est pas posé ton
criminelle vous entrez vous sortez vos
cartes du centre c'est son pseudonyme
d'afficher les ide brigitte bardot
brigitte bardot tu te prends rendez vous
aux affaires sociales tu es d'accord
avec ça ah ouais vous les chouchouter
trou et c'est pour ça qu'elle revienne
chez vous seulement 4% sont arrivés à se
réinsérer
on peut pas continuer à dépenser son
résultat on peut plus qu'est ce que
c'est que ça je compte aller réparer des
trucs se trouvent les autres aussi s à
faire des choses c'est peut-être comme
ça qu'on peut les aider
j'étais deux soignantes mais j'ai
travaillé dans une agence immobilière d
abord en combien de temps bonjour à ses
24 heures c'est beaucoup
on va vous confronter au monde du
travail
j'ai 56 ans je m'appelle et me dit non
tu t'appelles pas lady di est ce que tu
es lady di non tu donnes ton vrai nom
réparé de l'électroménager les
appréhende raison après j'ai tué mon
mari attend chantale j'aime pas manquer
les vêtements audriel dit pas qu'elle a
un problème avec les hommes attends je
mangeais aucun problème avec les hommes
voilà audrey l'appel mot et c'est pas
grave je vais rapporter des luminaires
de chez moi
comment veux-tu qu'elle soit autonome si
tu marches tout pour elle t'as pas vu
dans leurs regards l'espoir qu'est
revenue je sais pas comment elles sont
belles comment elles ont envie
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
pour lui didier
c'est à plumes hausse qui trouve un mec
est pas mal plus atteints ou d'engins
milliards
[Musique]
savon été repéré par une patrouille
japonaise
c'est maintenant ou jamais on aura
jamais assez de kérosène sur des cols de
ce point accrochez vous les gars
[Musique]
on arrive à tokyo
mais o2
qu'est ce qui se passe mais bon sang
qu'est ce qu'ils font
[Musique]
ou pas
j'aime aux lettres les japonais amis
accouchement
[Musique]